so Mark milley says he didn't know they
were drag queen story hours going on at
military bases but maybe more
significantly he's also not sure where
all the weapons that we're sending to
Ukraine have wound up so yesterday Joe
manchin Democrat from West Virginia
asked Millie if he could speak to his
quote confidence in the U.S NATO
Ukrainian weapons accountability here
was his response
we do not have any uniformed troops or
civilians for that matter accompanying
Ukrainian forces in the front line we do
have folks working out of the embassy so
they're working at the ministry of
Defense level and that's as far as our
on uh Hands-On accountability goes we do
have some other uh means through
reporting that the ukrainians report to
us and I'll be happy to talk about that
in a classified session but the there
are some means and mechanisms of doing
some accountability it is not as
rigorous as you might think
yeah not as rigorous JD Vance has served
the United States Marine Corps now he
serves in the United States Senate
representing the state of Ohio he joins
us tonight Senator thank you so much for
coming so when you hear the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs say we're not exactly
sure where the advanced weapon systems
are going how do you feel about that
well Tucker It's outrageous but
unfortunately it confirms what we
basically already know which is that
we've sent 113 billion dollars probably
more than that Tucker probably more like
130 billion dollars to the most corrupt
country on the face of the planet and we
have no real idea how those resources
have been spit the most important part
of this Tucker and I've done a very deep
dive into this is we do not make enough
bullets in this country to support
multiple fronts of multiple Wars so I'm
talking about bullets I mean ammunition
Munitions artillery shells some of the
advanced missile systems so when we talk
about sending 120 billion dollars worth
of weapons to Ukraine those are weapons
that we could not send to Taiwan or
other parts of the world that would
actually be in the service of American
National interest this entire idea that
we can focus on Russia and we can focus
on China is a farce these guys shipped
our entire industrial base to China in
the first place we don't make enough of
our own weapons and the fact that we're
sending it to Ukraine with so little
accountability is the very reason why
China's threat and power is growing in
the world today
yeah and we're about to lose the US
Dollars the world's Reserve currency and
tank our economy I agree with that I
Wonder has there been a concerted effort
from the Congress to find out who's
gotten Rich from this many people have
clearly do we know they are
uh we don't know who they are Tucker in
part because the bite Administration
won't give us answers I actually
submitted a letter one of the first
things that I did as a U.S senator is
ask for a full accounting of where the
resources that we've sent to Ukraine
have gone the by demonstration has been
very resistant even in classified
settings to be honest with us and truck
Tucker I have to be honest with you I'm
not sure it's if it's because they have
no idea where those 120 billion dollars
have gone or if they just don't want to
tell us but what we can be almost
certain is that some very dark very very
evil people have gotten very wealthy
from that 120 billion dollars I hope
that it's done some good too but the
simple fact is we don't know and there
has not been a full accounting of this
stuff
the recklessness is just awe-inspiring I
mean it's just drunk driving me in whole
country I mean it's unbelievable uh
Senator Vance of Ohio I appreciate your
coming on tonight thank you
thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight